we put on a disguise and maybe go see
what's happening down city I have to be
at work tomorrow I have to do rehearsal
and then I have to be back on the set of
big little eyes - on Monday and being
the professional that I am I am having
to go leave this afternoon so that I can
prep do my prep I get that by the way
Meryl Streep told us that you are a
great boss she loves having you as a
boss and she also said there was some
really boss come on I bowed down she's
like the she's the Empress she said
there were some great dinner parties
with cocktails involved - yeah we go out
we and we love eating Italian food in
Monterrey just giving a shout out
because the food in Monterrey is amazing
[Music]
is it true that the Atlanta the art for
it they use your face originally because
they wanted you before you had even
signed yeah it's so funny because um
James said to me I still want you to do
this and he said I'll prove to you that
I've always wanted you to do this you
know my renderings I drew you so what
are you gonna say boy your race they
just released that trailer they say
sometimes you got to hurt a child in
order to help them but I'm not quite
something
so much about love and it's about the
the strength of a mother and the warmth
of a mother and their tolerance and
teaching people to that love is love
obviously